I went to bed the night before the Nobel
Committee called me at 3:00 a.m. it's
noon in Stockholm that's traditionally
the time they announce it I didn't know
that at the time I went to bed not
knowing that the next day was the day
they would announce the price I had
never paid any attention to that
schedule so I it was just an ordinary
night I went to bed and a 3 a.m. the
phone rang in my son's bedroom with it
didn't ring in our bedroom because we
had our phone turned off we had two
teenaged boys in the house and there
were girls calling in all hours of the
night so we had turned our phone off so
our older son answered the phone and
came in and said dad and in a hushed
voice he didn't want to scare us
dad it's I think it was CBS CBS is on
the phone and they say they have good
news still he did not know what was
going on and through the fog I thought
my god it's October I got the word first
from the press the Nobel Committee in a
sort of almost characteristic manner had
gotten the wrong phone number for me and
the first person they called was an
engineer who also lived in my town who
also had my first name my name J Michael
and he responded you've got the wrong
guy I'm an engineer but I have their
phone number because these girls keep
calling here that's how they got the
phone number and they couldn't reach me
for quite a while because the press
dominated the incoming but the bottom
line is I was utterly surprised there
are there are many anecdotes about
people scientists who every year on the
magic night go to bed wondering whether
they're going to get the phone call the
next morning that was not true of me not
at all
you